[Music]
[Applause]
Rob gronowski he's got his own bowl game
Rob won four Super Bowls three with New
England one with Tampa Bay and uh the uh
grank Bowl actually it's called the LA
Bowl hosted by grank at Sofi Stadium
that'll be UCLA Boise State Bo eate on
uh December 16th grank joins us now ooh
look at the backdrop there you got a lot
of fun things in the office there what's
the coolest thing you have there I the
best thing in my office I would say is
definitely the three New England Patriot
Super Bowl replica trophies they're not
the real Vince Lombardi trophies but
they're replicas and it's the three that
I won with New England and the one I won
with Tampa is down in my crib uh down in
Florida so it's definitely the best
thing in here every time someone comes
through my house a friend a family
member or whoever it is they're always
in awe whenever they see these trophies
and they always ask is this the real one
and I always say yes and then I always
trick them like 10 seconds later and
then they look for the dent Dan they
look for the dent then and they're like
no this isn't the real one so I got to
put a dent in the one that that has the
dent um over at the Patriots Hall of
Fame but uh then I trickled I'm like
they're not the real one uh it's they're
just replicas but they love them when's
the last time you talked to
Brady uh I actually talked to him
yesterday and he sent me some highlights
um of us in the playoffs which was
really cool because uh I actually saw
some highlights of us on Instagram about
two weeks ago and I was like dang we
were legit we were legendary that's for
sure and wait wait grun did you
forget I kind of forgot you know I'm so
busy running around doing all the stuff
doing the analyst for Fox and stuff and
wow when I see the highlights man I
think we to we the top dogs man no one
did it better than us I swear man we on
fire that's for sure okay Kelsey and
momes they're legit you know you can't
take away anything from home but you
know I think Brady and grank just sounds
a little bit better man it has a better
ring to it what if it was a fight an
actual fist fight you and Brady versus
momes and Kelsey oh my gosh oh man
everyone always tries to compare us you
know us two versus them to or Travis
vers myself and every always takes a
different angle but all right I'm going
to answer I mean you asked so you know I
think we'll take him down I think we'll
win I mean hey but is Tom a good fighter
we hey Tom's a dog Tom's a dog and you
know something I saw what he said on his
podcast the other day with leanian
thinon yeah I got up I you know he said
it this way I wasn't a I got up from
every single hit and I gotta agree with
that and uh you know the rule starts
softening a little bit at the right time
for Tom Brady when he started going into
his 30s 35 years old into his 40s so it
helped him out tremendously the played
till about 45 years old but I've seen
some crazy crazy highlights of Tom Brady
when he was 24 years old 25 and he
absolutely got lit up harder than any
quarterback I've ever seen in my life
and I'm sitting there like damn Tom I
didn't know you used to take hits like
this and he got up every single time so
you got to give him that credit man well
I go back to that Super Bowl with the
Giants grank and I was on the sidelines
watching that he and I remember strayan
telling me he never had more respect for
Brady then after that Super Bowl with
the punishment they gave him and he
never ever
complained that's 100% true in every
injury that Tom ever had to he's never
complained he always found a way to get
back out on the practice field the next
day or to continue practice for example
when he ripped open his hand before the
Jacksonville game the AFC Championship
game um I don't know six years ago or
whatever it was I saw it happen I mean
he he screamed like like a mofo that's
for sure because who won it I mean you
ripped your freaking whole thumb open
but let me tell you it didn't hold him
down he was out there for the game so
nothing holds him down man the guy's a
warrior and uh so if you're ever in a
battle with him you know he's gonna keep
battling until you freaking knock him
out or freaking demolish him so you know
he's going to keep fighting for you
that's for sure when's the last time you
talked to
belich was actually on Tom's podcast
when he
retired so everything has to go back to
Tom so uh I was on Tom whatever the
podcast he does on sirusxm yeah and then
he was having everyone come on he had
pton Manny come on and then I I started
making fun of Tom with pton Manny saying
Tom ripped your plays off of you pton
Manny that's why we were so successful
and then all of a sudden coach ballad
cheack came on too at the same time and
then we just started bannering back and
forth it was great interaction man it
was awesome he's Rob gronowski won four
Super Bowls and he is the host of the uh
La Bowl it'll be at Sofi It's UCLA Boise
State okay how did this happen and
what's your role in the bowl game once
it
starts yeah so it kind of happened I
mean they had Jimmy Kimmel as the host
the last two years and it was the first
two years the LA ball was established
and uh then you know uh his contract or
whatever expired and then they're moving
on to you know find an athlete and they
hit up my team uh they hit out my
management and asked if I would be you
know interested in hosting the LA bowl
and right when I you know heard about
the LA bowl and if I was interested it
definitely clicked and you want to know
why it clicked is because it was the
bowl game that I last played my last
game at the University of Arizona at
with my brother Chris and that game was
actually in Las Vegas at at the time it
was a Las Vegas Bowl but it was the
fifth place uh pack ten seed versus the
first place Mountain West
so that conference matchup has now moved
to LA the last two years so it's
technically the last ball game I played
Willie to atama over 300 yards my
brother Chris up the middle for about a
30 yard touchdown off play action we
beat BYU by 10 points I think and they
were ranked number 17 in the country at
the time so it was my last college
football game I didn't score a touchdown
I didn't have that good of a game but we
won it was the first time Arizona was in
a ball game in 10 years we won the ball
game as well so right when that clicked
wow I get to host a bow game that was my
last college game and we won that bow
game that's a no-brainer I'm all in
let's do it that's cool that's cool are
you singing The Anthem yes and I will be
singing the National Anthem as well
we're gonna have dance off and
I'll but Dan I'm not singing the
National Anthem by myself so I was with
him and I sung the National Anthem to
him and they all started plug in their
ears I was with Julian Edelman at the
moment and Julian Edelman goes bro let
me take 10 more shots of tequila and
then
I I'm on practice I got the words down
but I'm also saying it the new
directions veterans choir okay so it's
it's consisted of uh men and women who
have served proudly in the United States
uh military so I'll be singing with them
so I have a little backup behind me so I
you know I don't you know so it looks
they're making me look good that's
basically what they're do can we get
just a sample
I man my throat hurts I'll just give you
I'll just give you the first one oh
say there we go first two words okay
here's the key it's to be in the right
key when you start don't start up too
high or you're going to have a Carl
Lewis moment where you get up way too
high and you can't come back down start
out low oh say can you see oh man damn
I'm gonna need you to sing it with me as
well no no no that'll be guilt by
association I want you to do it yourself
and let you stand out I I don't want any
blame if it doesn't go well I'm G to ask
them if I can sing the last line by
myself like have the choir just totally
zip it and then I hit the last line
and
free and just have start hyping up the
crowd they go crazy when's the last time
you hit
somebody oh man oh man hit somebody I
mean I would say the last game uh I
would say like actual hit hit somebody
do you do you miss like do you miss
contact uh no not really man I've been
having contact my whole life ever since
I was four years old with my brothers in
the basement playing mini stick hockey
there's actually home videos of us uh
Christmas Eve and my mom's filming that
all of a sudden there was such a big hit
my brother went flying to the ground
stitches all in his face I'm the one who
level him he's going to the hospital so
like hitting's been in my culture in my
life since I was a young kid but man I
don't really miss it that much anymore I
love activities I love I love the sports
where there's not much contact
volleyball cornhole but hitting wise I
got hit enough in my life what was your
second best sport I would say I would go
with uh I would say baseball all the way
up until I was about 14 years old and
then I started declining big time
because I think I started lifting and
getting too big I couldn't really swing
that much anymore but then basketball
was my second favorite to play in high
school because it was just like we had
such a great atmosphere at our school we
had we had a crowd called the green
Squall and they would just come and
harass the other team the whole time
they would go crazy if I dunked the ball
so basketball was a lot of fun in high
school I'm glad you're doing well and
it's weird how people keep they push
athletes or ask it when you going to
retire when you're going to retire and
then you retire and then they say when
you're going to come back it felt like
now you're past that moment that people
aren't asking you on a semi-regular
basis of hey would you come back no I
would say the first time I retired I got
it basically every single day wherever I
went and then I would say the second
time I retired which was over I don't
know like a year ago or whatever yeah I
still got it a lot I didn't get it as
much and now I still get it like
probably like once a week maybe once
every other week but it's not at a
consistent basis anymore like it was
before it was like every day man so it's
I'm glad I'm past that I'm glad it's not
every single day cuz it kind of gets
annoying you're trying to do something
and someone just ask you out of nowhere
when you're coming back you know so um
that's in the past now and uh just
moving on the the I would say I wouldn't
say bigger better things because playing
football is big and it's and it's
awesome to play football but I'm moving
on to great things uh like hosting the
LA bow I'm doing the fox analyst stuff
so a lot of cool things like that man to
keep me busy because you got to stay
busy man I like having my time off
there's no doubt about it I like having
five days doing whatever I want but also
man I got to work as well and uh staying
busy is definitely a staple to keep me
going I'm worried about you getting USAA
insurance though grank I don't think
you're ever gonna get it I don't I don't
think I'm ever gonna get it either and I
just jumped out of the plane when we
were at the army base when uh for the
fox pregame show when we did it at the
not the army base the Air Force Base in
Colorado jumped out of a plane with uh
one of the Air Force guys that had over
3,500 jumps so I felt very safe and uh I
was flipping and doing all that good
stuff I landed and then all the cadetes
were there as well there was about 200
of them and they all ask me does that
get you
us I'm like no it doesn't and then the
one kid was like marry my sister that
will give you USA insurance I was like
oh man we're going to another level now
yeah uh good luck with the LA bow and
thanks for joining us grun hey Dan
thanks for having me man December 16th
La Bowl Boise State vers UCLA and uh I
don't know who I'm cheering for yet
thanks bud yes thanks for having me man
it's Rob gronowski